I used to guess this question a lot in
the beginning not so much anymore
because I think pretty much at least
academically speaking people are coming
around to the idea that entrepreneurship
is teachable now the question of whether
this logic is teachable I think this
logic is even more teachable in the
sense that it doesn't depend on any
particular set of criteria so I don't
have to give you some kind of
psychological tests and say you know
here are three things you need to change
about yourself before you can be an
entrepreneur so I tell my students it's
something like a voice and my teaching
you to sing there are aspects to it you
have to want to do it if you never ever
want to start a venture I'm not going to
go try to motivate you to start a
venture it's not about that kind of
thing but given that you want to start a
venture there are lots of things that
are teachable there are lots of basic
techniques like cash flow and you can
teach but I think I'm very fortunate to
have found something that is teachable
also at the worldview level so there are
ways to teach people to think
differently just like you can teach
people to think scientifically it
doesn't mean they're you know not going
to you know refuse to walk under a
ladder it doesn't mean that they all
become some kind of super rationalist
like Newton but everybody can pause and
think but let me look at that
scientifically you know maybe I
shouldn't be superstitious and that's
teachable I think it's in that sense
entrepreneurial thinking or this logic
of entrepreneurship is very much
teachable I can't force people to
actually get out and do something but if
they want to do something I think there
are lots of things that we can teach
them about how to do it better that is
more likely to lead to novelty it's more
likely to lead to a more satisfying kind
of entrepreneurship if you were so the
lots of things that are teachable
assuming people actually want to learn
how to start a venture one of the first
things I tell them is started and so
people look at me like what but the
thing is I ask them okay so you want to
start a venture what venture do you want
to start and people would say things
like oh I want to start a mentor but I
don't have an idea all right you know I
have an idea but I don't have money so I
try to go through that list and take
away their reasons for not doing it and
it's very easy to do that because you
can come up with examples of
entrepreneurs over and over again who
did things without having an idea and
without having any resources and with
four kids after a divorce which didn't
give you any money I mean there are
examples of entrepreneurs who have done
it every which way that you can imagine
and almost all the time and people think
about here are three things that you
need before you start a venture almost
all of them are always falsified in most
great entrepreneurial stories so I have
lots of stories if you would like me to
go into one or two of them so one of the
stories is google right now we think
it's like the greatest idea in the whole
universe but when Google came along it
was just another search engine tether I
don't remember how many exactly were
like 65 viable search engines on the
market something like that it was yet
another search engine maybe a couple of
you know tech savvy people in Silicon
value knew that there was something
special about it but when their first
investor actually gave them a check they
did have a bank account they hadn't
incorporated he gave a check on google
inc and they had to open a bank account
later so even they did not really you
know believe that this is going to be
the greatest thing in fact there is a
story that they tried to sell the
company for 1 million dollars and you
know luckily I say for them nobody was
and there were no takers so they
couldn't sell it so they had to you know
perforce become billionaires that does
not sound to me like somebody who had
this great vision for a good idea
another example is Piero media and he
gave a convocation talk at Tufts various
crises that people always tell me that
you must have known that ebay had to be
self-sustaining otherwise it couldn't
you know manage with 40 million users
that they or whatever it was at that
time and he said no I build a system
that would be self-sustaining because
you know I had a life then he said you
know ebay was not my only thing i had a
day job i had a girlfriend and we wanted
to go mountain biking on the weekends
and so I had it been something that
would just capture feedback and do
everything on its own while we were away
having a life and he goes on to say that
if I had gotten a lot of money from a
venture capital capitalist I might have
done something more complicated and it
wouldn't have worked the way eb has
worked out so here's another person but
it doesn't mean that they have no ideas
they're just doing things that they know
how to do and they're trying to push it
he he has a day job but he's trying to
build something build a venture on the
side too so you can talk about these
things people having ideas resources and
I also show video clips in class Robert
rise who found at rnr they had they sold
trivial pursuit in the millions right so
he talks about it and he has a very good
way he says that it's like playing
scrabble a lot of people think that you
have to have some kind of blockbuster
idea i'm actually quoting him now by the
way but he says it's like scrabble you
know its most ideas on monday and you
add a letter to a word and then you get
the credit for the whole world you know
so I so I play that clip in class and I
talk about that a little bit and there
are a whole series of exercises that you
can do and one of them is I ask students
to think about who they are what they
know in whom they know and to come up
with a couple of possible venture ideas
that they can start the next day and
then if nothing else I let them do
something every day about it and it
could be something as I'm as simple as
coming up with a name and getting a card
printed so so long as you actually do
something it becomes real somehow
and then people start doing things and
then I get them to call people and talk
to them get advice and then all kinds of
advice starts pouring in you should do
this you should not do that and you know
you should make it bigger it should be
like this maybe you should add this chip
or you should look at this technology
and then they start getting all this
feedback and a lot of people even start
picking up the phone and calling other
people to introduce them and very soon
it becomes very very real so there's
absolutely no substitute I think to
actually getting people to start a
venture even if starting a venture might
be something as it might seem idiotic
like you know come up with a name and
print a card it could be the starting
point but then the pushing is where I
think the real learning happens so what
do you do next I think is the essence of
entrepreneurial teaching so the first of
us to get them to do something and then
you start looking into this problem of
what do you do next so in a way I almost
think about entrepreneurship now in
terms of content in teaching as the art
of the next step that entrepreneurs are
always about the next step because a lot
of people do you know come up with an
idea and a name and a business card and
then they stop but as entrepreneurs are
very good at going out and talking to
people and then responding to all the
suggestions and sometimes even the
criticisms that they get with always
another action that is doable and worth
doing in the small and then they push it
and then I push it
you